we are living in a state of urgency with
this corona virus outbreak today's hero
group will be dedicated to our response
to the economic fallout of this virus
due to the tight restrictive measures in
place and to ensure all countries are
represented at minister level we will
meet via video call
I will table a statement that sets out a
new coordinated policy response it
includes initiatives to contain and
treat the disease liquidity support to
firms particularly SME support workers
and Families measures that will help
bridge this gap until the virus rains
off on the other hand we will ensure
that you fiscal rules or state aid rules
will not stand in the way of supporting
our economies flexibility is there and
will be fully used national efforts go
hand in hand with initiatives led by EU
institutions such as the European
Commission the EIB and also the European
Central Bank together we are giving a
powerful response but we know the virus
hasn't reached its peak
we must not kid ourselves these are the
first steps in a temporary but long
fight forced containment is bringing our
economies to warlike times we will also
discuss next steps and all European
institutions will be exploring ways to
help us defeat these crisis and return
to normality